نعلن عن أول خطاف واضح لدينا ،
أطلقنا عليه اسم SA واحد ، إنه اسم رمزي
ولكن به ثمانية دوارات لدوارات الإمالة
وأربعة دوارات شفة مما يعني أن
أربعة دوارات يمكن إمالتها لأعلى ولأسفل
اعتمادًا على وضع الطيران ويمكنك
حمل أربعة  ركاب مع طيار
وهو مصمم حقًا للسفر داخل المدينة
ولكنه أيضًا يمكن أن يخدم
سكان الريف أيضًا ، لذلك نحن متحمسون للغاية
كشركة معروفة بصناعة
السيارات والسيارات التي ندخلها في
أعمال جديدة جدًا ولكننا  واثقون جدًا من
قدرتنا على جعل هذه الحقبة الجديدة
من الطيران حقيقة واقعة وإمكانية
لكل شخص تعرفه ، حيث سيكون هناك الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين ينظرون إلى هذا ويقولون إنك
تعلم انتظرًا ، لماذا هذا في
النهاية أفضل من طائرة هليكوبتر ،
هل يمكنك شرح  الجواب هو لماذا هذا
يتفوق على المروحية ، والفرق
بين المروحية
والمروحيات التقليدية وهذا النوع من التصميم هو
أساسًا مستوى الضوضاء وأيضًا يكون
قادرًا على توزيع الدوارات متعددة
الدوارات لأن  يمكننا وضع
محركات كهربائية هي محركات كهربائية فردية
لكل مروحة على عكس المروحية
حيث يجب أن يكون لديك محرك كبير
لتدوير دوارنا الرئيسي ، لذا فإن فائدة
هذا النوع من التصميم على UAM هي
تقليل مستوى ضوضاء الضوضاء قليلاً
جدًا لذلك  يمكنك بالفعل العمل في المدينة
، كما أنه يزيد من السلامة لأن
لديك
عدة دوارات إذا فشل أحدها ،
فيمكن للآخرين تحمل العبء ،
لذا فإن الضوضاء المتزايدة للسلامة
وهذا هو السبب في أننا نعتقد أنه يمكننا
بالفعل تشغيل هذا في مدينة